c'est quand il appelle sauver notre dame
il y avait beaucoup de monde pour être
élu là il faut sauver l'hôpital public
qui retrace flambé à la même vitesse que
notre dame a failli flamber ça s'est
joué à rien et là en ce moment ça se
joue à rien je vais pas d'autres choses
à faire pour inscrire votre compte sur
vous ah oui les comptes et sont à la
baisse rémois restent à prouver
maintenant
je suis là parce que derrière il passé
pour nous en tant que lecteur des
citoyens on est au bout on est vraiment
on a beaucoup couru et non pour
l'instant mené à la crise prenez la
route
c'est vrai que je suis désolé bonjour a
prôné la main et donner les moyens nous
c'est la santé
le mariage polygame donnez-lui les
moyens de donner les moyens de soigner
notation les personnels hospitaliers
le corps soignant qui dans son ensemble
a fait tous les efforts nécessaires
nous sommes allés au bout oui mais on a
besoin d'un choc d'attractivité il faut
absolument pour financer en urgence
pourtant je ne suis pas là pour moi
j'avais compris j'étais je suis là vous
savez qui est derrière moi l'ensemble du
koursk ou non et on peut pas se
contenter des finalement je me suis
désolé mais moi d'accord mais on est
passé par un angle délits d'après on a
fait ce constat
maintenant il faut agir alors moi le
fond de ma pensée c'est que kairos et le
moment opportun et le moment opportun
pour le président de la république il
agir même dans une situation dont il
n'est pas responsable c'est maintenant
qu'il faut saisir
le risque est grand pas seulement du
fait que cette épidémie on ne sait pas
comment elle va évoluer
le risque est grand parce que le système
en tout cas des hôpitaux publics est
actuellement je dirais en partie
sinistrés
en d'autres termes les moyens qu'il faut
injecter pour qu'il y ait des personnels
pour s'occuper des cds moyens qui sont
urgentistes sans injection de moyens
rapides nous ne pourrons pas faire face
à ce type de crise effectivement au
moment des attentats
les personnels soignants sont revenus
travailler effectivement que se
satisfaire que les grèves qui était
urgente et plus continuer tout ça c'est
très bien mais on n'est pas dans la même
situation actuellement la situation
s'est considérablement aggravée et je
pense qu'il est la responsabilité des
tutelles en général et du président la
république qui est le protecteur de
l'ensemble de la nation d'assumer ce
rôle et c'est maintenant c'est tout de
suite c'est à dans six mois c'est pas
dans un jeu d antan du docteur je veux
juste qu'on est collectivement
l'honnêteté de se dire je suis comme
vous je crois au kairos mais le kairos
il doit intervenir dans un moment de
vérité
ce moment de vérité c'est aussi qu'on
n'est pas resté assis sur sa chaise
depuis deux ans et demi nous accorderait
et donc je dis pas que nous en
reparlerons c'est ce qui justifie de
d'attendre je suis pas pour attendre
j'ai parfois le sentiment de payer
l'addition de beaucoup de comptes qui
sont restés et non soldés je veux bien
les prendre mais je vais au moins avoir
un petit peu de reconnaissance on sera
transparent là dessus c'est bien mais en
tout cas je indépendamment de ça je vous
remercie infiniment pour la mobilisation
et l'esprit de responsabilité des autres
parce que
vous êtes au service de nos concitoyens
avec un formidable engagement et une
humanité que je ici saluer donc merci
beaucoup